this video is kindly sponsored by
masterworks find out more later on hey
42 here funny how some words stick with
you isn't it i distinctly remember the
first time i heard the word bedlam i was
a child and we're in a crowded shopping
center on christmas eve
you can picture the scene wild eyes
foaming mouths the war cries of fully
grown adults commencing shopping based
battle over the last tamagotchi on the
shelf
pure bedlam that's how one man describes
this terrifying glimpse into the pure
cray-cray that simmers just below the
surface of your average christmas
shopper as closing time approaches
it's an unassuming word bedlam it means
chaos and confusion but it's usually
used to describe fairly innocuous
situations a children's birthday party
when the jelly and cake induced sugar
rush kicks in
or the wild celebrations after your
favorite sports team records an
important victory in the cult
but don't let the modern usage fool you
because the origin of the word bedlam
traces its roots back through history to
one of the most infamous and brutal
institutions
the world has ever seen this is the
story of bethlehem royal hospital
better known as bedlam mental asylum
now i've got a mystery for all of you
that's evaded an answer for almost a
century
why would one of the richest families in
history store almost a billion dollars
of their wealth away in fine art well
there's lots of theories and maybe we'll
never know for sure but we do know some
facts about contemporary art today
contemporary art prices outpace the s p
500 by 164 percent from 1995 to 2021
with numbers like that you can start to
imagine why the rockefellers are part of
a trend that continues today
where over two-thirds of billionaires
allocate more than 20
of their overall portfolio to art now
the mystery is
how do you do it
well that i can give you a concrete
answer to
with masterworks i've talked about them
on this channel before and i think what
they're doing is genius well some of you
may think it's too expensive to get
access to well i want to put that notion
to rest forget what you thought about
the art market and that it's reserved
for the ultra wealthy in fact members of
the 42 community have already invested
with masterworks and with the stock
market being so crazy recently and
equity firms predicting real returns of
5 or less now is the right time to look
at diversifying your portfolio
and masterworks is how i'm choosing to
do that and luckily for you masterworks
has provided my viewers with priority
access so go check them out using the
link in the description and see the new
offering that they have on their
platform effluent royal hospital was the
uk's very first insane asylum i'm the
first institution in europe to focus
solely on treating the mentally ill
today's version of the hospital can be
found in beckenham kent and though it's
existed on several sites over the years
it's always been regarded as a leading
center of its time for the treatment of
mental illness of course that hasn't
always been anything much to be proud of
you don't have to go too far back in
history before you reach a time when
cutting edge treatments for ailments of
the mind meant spinning your patient in
a chair suspended from the ceiling until
they passed out vomited or bled from the
ears
but i'm getting ahead of myself the
establishment that would one day become
known as bedlam first opened its doors
as a priory dedicated to saint mary of
bethlehem close to 800 years ago in
1247.
it was commissioned as a way of
collecting donations for the crusades
rather than as a hospital but like many
religious institutions it also provided
sanctuary for those with nowhere else to
go
the original building was erected on top
of a sewer that regularly overflowed
and
that was fitting because bethlehem would
soon become home to people that society
at the time viewed as little more than
human waste
like nail salons and money laundering
poverty and mental illness have often
been linked from the outset the people
bethlehem would have taken in were
likely to be destitute as well as
suffering from various forms of mental
illness bethlehem officially became a
hospital in 1337 though in medieval
times hospital really just meant a place
for those in need which included
societies disabled and abandoned
doctors were also unrecognizable from
their modern counterparts they needed no
qualifications and rather than spending
many years learning the impossible
intricacies of the human body
they pretty much just rocked up to work
one day and figured things out through
trial and error
well error
[Music]
putting your life in the hands of a
doctor in the 1200s was a bit like
trusting a pilot who's trained by flying
paper airplanes or asking an engineer to
build your house because he's pretty
handy with lego
i.e there was a good chance it was going
to get you killed the first concrete
evidence of people of mental illness
being treated at bethlehem
comes from a report written in 1403 as
well as recording the number of patients
suffering from insanity in the hospital
at the time six the report also rather
ominously made an inventory of some of
the equipment in use including four
pairs of manacles six locks eleven
chains and two pairs of stocks
the purpose of these items wasn't
specified in the report but i think it's
pretty obvious what it was all for
bdsm
well either that or to restrain the
patients i guess
by 1406 bethlehem had shifted from the
role of general hospital to purely
focusing on being an insane asylum and
the building had become a london
landmark in medieval times it was
believed that madness was brought about
by a disease of the body and strong
medicines were used to purge the patient
in a one one-size-fits-all kind of
approach
in addition to bouts of induced vomiting
and diarrhea bloodletting was also
practiced
another way of literally drawing out the
melancholy was by applying abrasive
substances to the skin causing it to
blister
just in case anyone started to feel too
comfortable whilst being subject to this
routine torture i mean treatment regular
degradations like head shaving and
freezing cold baths were administered
too
the people of london have a long history
of playing around with language and over
the centuries the word bethlehem
eventually morphed into bedlam
by the 1600s this new word had
infiltrated the english language so
completely that it's still in common use
today though most people have no idea if
it's disturbing origin
one of the main reasons for bedlam's
infamy was that from around the 1550s
patients with metal identification
armbands were sent out into the streets
of london to beg for money to support
the hospital's maintenance
these pitiful souls were clearly
successful
if i can even use that word in this
context
bedlam's poor were named as one of the
main sites of london and in 1598 the
governors of bethlehem decided to open
the hospital doors to spectators who
would pay to watch the asylum's
inhabitants
in what became a literal human zoo
profiting from thousands of paying
visitors coming to ogle mentally ill
patients is perhaps one of the most
scandalous parts of bedlam's history
but the campaign netted the institution
around 400 pounds a year more than 70
000 pounds in today's money which
probably explains why it went on for
almost two centuries
what's a little moral depravity when
there's money to be made hey
with demand for the unique
entertainments available at bethlehem on
the rise a new building was constructed
in 1676.
not only was bethlehem 2.0 larger than
the institution it replaced it was also
unbelievably grand inspired by the
tulares palace in paris it soon became
known as a palace for lunatics but a
turd still stinks no matter how much
chanel number five you spray on it and
despite the fancy makeover bethlehem
hospital remained a truly awful place
for all those unlucky enough to find
themselves on the wrong side of its
tastefully designed walls
[Music]
doctors posts were passed on to family
and friends ensuring that primitive and
torturous treatments endured if you're
wondering how the hospital's inmates
were able to withstand such abuse
the simple truth is
they didn't modern investigations have
unearthed mass graves where brutalized
patients were simply piled on top of one
another and forgotten about
all in all there wasn't anything
progressive about the new bedlam
it was all a front
it did achieve one of its primary goals
though it attracted more paying tourists
with those visitors came pickpockets
food vendors and even prostitutes
and hospital staff would bolster their
income by offering private tours
due to overwhelming numbers especially
during holidays the number of paying
visitors began to be restricted from
about 1770 and by the 1780s calls to
reform the system saw public tours
stopped altogether on the face of it
that was a good thing
but it came with an unexpected and
unfortunate side effect
there was now less outside scrutiny than
ever on what went on behind bedlam's
gates
in 1728 dr james monroe was appointed as
a physician of bedlam he was the first
in a family dynasty of infamous doctors
four of whom would be responsible for
bethlehem's patients for the next 150
years in an incredible display of
nepotism
these physicians were hugely influential
two of them were even consulted in the
case of mad king george iii he was well
known to suffer from mental illness
the methods applied by the monroes in
bethlehem were criticized as being
outdated and cruel
there was a focus on restraint beatings
and general mistreatment of the patients
who could just as easily have been
described as prisoners
one of the most vocal critics of
bethlehem's practices was dr william
batty the chief physician of nearby
saint luke's hospital for poor lunatics
at st luke's there was no public
viewings little use of restraints and
generally a more humane treatment of
patients
around 70 of patients were cured in
comparison to around 15 percent in other
poorer asylums like bethlehem where
methods were rooted in archaic ideas
about mental illness being linked with
sin or possession by demons
it wasn't until 1815 and a parliamentary
investigation into the running of
so-called mad houses in england
that a spotlight was finally shown on
the horror of places like bethlehem as
the extent of the depravities were
uncovered bedlam head honcho thomas
monroe was forced to resign though
naturally his son edward thomas monroe
was waiting in the wings to take over
the family business of
caring for england's mentally ill like
his father before him edward thomas
preferred to stick to
traditional methods but that all changed
with his son henry monroe the last in
the lineage of what became known as the
mad doctors of bedlam
unlike the four monroes before him henry
wrote published works on mental illness
and held progressive beliefs he was
against the practices that had been
advocated by his family and in 1854 he
was appointed physician at saint luke's
bethlehem's fierce rival
the findings of the parliamentary
committee in 1815 made it clear that the
methods employed at bedlam desperately
needed to be overhauled and so did the
building itself it was dilapidated the
floors were buckled none of the walls
were vertical and the roof leaked
like some of the patients it housed
bedlam was pronounced to be
incurable
sections of the building had to be
closed off because they were essentially
uninhabitable
which in turn resulted in an
overcrowding of patients elsewhere
dangerous patients were placed in cells
of those who were more placid
meaning fights were commonplace and
fatalities far from unheard of patients
would often be changed together many
were naked except for a blanket and
there was no heating or hot water
all in all it's fair to say there wasn't
much chance of anybody at bethlehem
actually getting cured of anything
the following few decades saw the board
of governors at bethlehem opposed the
reforms imposed upon them by the
parliamentary committee
but their resistance ended in 1851 when
the institution was finally taken into
public hands
ending six centuries of independence
the hospital's notoriety was gradually
brought under control and in 1930 the
establishment was moved to its
present-day location in kent
as conditions improved so the nickname
bedlam faded
most people who use the word these days
have no idea where it came from
but perhaps that's for the best
in a world where treatment for the
mentally ill is becoming better
understood with every passing year
some horrors are better left in the past
where they belong
thanks for watching